welcome to put a type on it together
we're going to go on a journey a journey
about discovery and this is in part now
that I've got you in this room this is
my confession right um this is about it
recite providers but it's about my
philosophy on how we can make
infrastructure and software a lot more
reasonable so i'll be your host my name
is Susan Potter and for the last 10 ish
years of my 18-year career I've been
trying to build services that are a bit
more reasonable to varying degrees right
and I've done a lot of work with
distributed systems and back-end kind of
stuff but a lot of people actually know
me as a ruby developer and i also have
done my fair share of slinging java and
apparently some people think i should be
indoors for agile methodologies i hope
they were jokes but but my excuse my
experience is very of you are in
industry you're not researchers right
yeah the vast majority of you and how
many of you work on what many would
consider mainstream stacks okay great so
that's most of you this that's great
that's kind of what I've targeted this
tool cat and so if I can do it there's
hope for every single one of you people
okay and not that I've done anything
right but I'm sharing my experiences
with you right okay so questions feel
free to ask questions they're welcome
throughout the session I will be
checking in with you right as well right
but do feel free if if there's something
on the slide that just doesn't make
sense or you think it's a typo please
bring it up I might defer some of the
more philosophical questions to the end
okay so I was going to put in a PHP
error in here that I got one morning
this week I'm just randomly on
right and to as an example of a type
error and that was really a lame straw
man so what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to make some i'm going to show you
an error that i think most people would
not consider a type error or should not
be a type error or may I don't know that
they would think it would be a type
error and that is how many here are
familiar with AWS ec2 kind of lingo okay
and most of you well I'm easy to is part
of AWS Amazon Web Services and you can
launch instances which are kind of like
virtual servers right and so I'm just
trying to explain some of the
terminology and if you launch in an
instance and it well one day I launched
an instance and it gave me back this
right and so basically what this is
saying is that I didn't my account did
not actually have the ability to spin up
an instance in this availability so now
this is actually from a few years ago
before v pcs but it still kind of counts
right I think and basically availability
zone mappings are specific to the
account and they're per region so AWS
has this notion of regions if you wanted
to put your server infrastructure on the
east coast of us as a u.s. East one
right if you wanted to kind of target
maybe West Coast users you know there's
uswest one and US west to right and this
is actually what my mappings look like
on my account right this is actually a
free this is my personal one read this
is like one of those started out as a
free tier thing and I hardly use it
right but you know I've got to
availability zones available in u.s.
west 13 in u.s. west to and for any was
a u.s. East one now this happened like I
only had three availability zones just a
couple of months ago and so this
happened this grew in the last couple of
months and I didn't know about it I
don't know where you find out about this
kind of stuff but Amazon just adds them
i guess i don't know right so this is a
common solution so I've worked with a
lot of ruby right
on infrastructure and serve a code right
this is kind of very typical now it may
not be hardcoded per se right it may be
read in from a yamel file or something
like that but typically there's some
kind of thing where people manage you
know the bindings or the mappings of the
availability zones per region right and
um they'll do something like this and
what what's the problem with this right
well the problem with this is well
whether you're hard coding this in Ruby
or you've got two thousand lines of
config yem old files right by the way I
that was a quote from this afternoon I
heard someone just randomly say that so
this exists by the way and and to be
honest I think I've seen a thousand line
config llamo files right so over time
this kind of thing leads to style
assumptions about your operating
environment right it is also kind of a
very reactive thing you usually don't
always something your organization
usually doesn't have someone who is
committed to updating those files right
as soon as you get available is owns
available right to your account right
you also have typically a lot of
organizations have multiple accounts and
those mappings are totally you know
dependent on the account so this isn't
code that is transferable across many
accounts so what can we do about it well
okay let's talk a little bit about the
problem space that I are really looking
to solve right number one is that I want
to have these derived rules and policies
right so I want to have this general
idea or template of a rule that I want
to apply this could be a rule thats
related to some consistency or
availability concerns on the emphasis
slide it could be something related to
finance right so one particular service
can't use more than so much a month
right or shouldn't or it should alert or
something along those lines and or it
could be just simply that the service
engineers say oh well this
needs to have it needs to be deployed or
provisioned with EBS optimized machines
or something like that now those are the
kinds of policies that I actually do
want to be able to define right I want
to define that in a highest level
language right and I want it to be
something that we can evolve over time
and that is fairly simple right I also
want to be able to validate existing
deployments that are already in the our
cloud right providers and I want to get
to the point to where we can validate
deployments against policies before we
even deploy in the first place right and
over the long run I want this high level
language that is that can give us some
assertions right it's not just managed
it's not just a defined sort of bit of
Ruby code that does this because what we
could have done is we could have had
Ruby hit the service that tells us what
what availability zones are available to
our account right but then we have like
all of this you know code dribbled all
over the place right and it's not
necessarily the kind of thing that I
want to be managing right and it also
doesn't give us very many assertions or
assurance of that our validations are in
fact sound right and we'll get to that
towards the end of the talk so so why
reason about infrastructure now I think
we're at a point where distributed
systems you can't get away from them
right so we have to deal with this
complexity or anyway regardless right we
have this Louise lawns kind of need so
we need to deal with it we also have
really high turn turn and turn over in
operations especially but also
developers and this creates work
environment that I think is demotivating
it is exhausting it is tiring and it
doesn't produce the
kind of the most creative or innovative
solutions to a problem right and it just
burns people out this is not the kind of
environment that I want to work in and I
think a lot of people are starting to
realize this and starting to acknowledge
this as a problem and technologically I
think functional programming and
expressive type systems are no longer
for academics and I think especially on
the functional programming side there
have been lots of inner roads made all
over the place from front end to
backhand and also now I think we're
starting to see some being done on
infrastructure side right and expressive
type systems sure there could be a
little bit more work done to make them
more accessible to industry developers
but it's getting there right and I'm
definitely seeing strides in that
direction we also have programmable
infrastructure everywhere right so
whether you're you've got a data center
you've probably got something that you
can program against whether you're in
AWS Google Cloud it doesn't matter right
so these kinds of things are realities
now and I think this is hopefully going
to create a turning point for us all
these three things kind of converging at
once ok so what is a type provider a
type provider it's a it's a mechanism
for constructing types right from
external sources so if you wanted to you
could create types for your database
schema right you could create types
based off of JSON data you could create
types based off of the header
information of the CSV file these kinds
of things and so it the the schema or
the metadata needs to be somewhat stable
for the duration of the running program
and the running program is the compiler
right there come the type checker in
this particular case right and of course
you want to be generating programs that
will that will be valid for a little
time right but our requirement is that
at the time of deployment and
provisioning we are able to take
advantage of all the capabilities that
our AWS account gives us right and
that's not just available at ease
availability zones per region that's
also the kinds of services that are
available to us in different regions
right so
some of our some accounts are kind of
preferred accounts and they get early
access to certain things that are only
available in certain regions right and
some service developers may want to be
able to deploy their okay so so how do
we make a sorry so how do we type
providers work well a lot of them in
other languages like f sharp and Scala
and Haskell although not necessarily all
of them utilize some form of source or
byte code generation as part of the
solution and so that that's how they
build their types and that's cool but it
also doesn't mean that we can reason
about whether or not the program that
they've generated behind the scenes is
actually well-formed okay so this is
what something this is what a Jason type
provider looks like an F sharp and on
line 6 the interesting thing here is
that we give it a prototype all kind of
bit of Jason that we want it to infer
some kind of type and then on line 9
what we can do is just give it some
throw actual data at it and tell and
then what is put as the value in aw is
actually a record type it is a value of
the record sk right and then we have
access to the attributes right as types
any questions sorry ok and then what so
how are addressed I provide is different
well we can compute types in Idris
itself right and because of its
dependent types and so what we have here
is an example piece of code we're with
the the name of the type itself is csv
type so that's so that's the declaration
on line number one line number two we
have this constructor this value
constructor make csv type and we accept
a delimiter character as an argument a
nap which is a natural number as a
second argument and a header which is a
vector of length n of strings and then
we can we can give back the CSV this
instance of
sv type that's all this is saying does
this make sense to everyone that's these
oops sorry so these funny things here
that's just saying that go to the next
argument so to speak with the next thing
the next type in a function so if you're
familiar at all with just reading
Haskell or scala in scala this would be
the equals greater than sign so i'm
still awake ok yes go ahead oh ok great
so so Idris so here's what so we will
let's review the provider type ok in a
dress and this is what we have to return
back inside of an IO action to be able
to create this type provider and I am
who here is familiar a little bit with
either Haskell or scholar ok oh great ok
fantastic so basically provider is like
the either except we only have we only
have one type argument right and we've
fixed the second type argument of either
to string this is basically all it is
right so this this is an either where
the error side is in fact string that's
it ok so how do we start off well we at
least we've declare a module to put our
provider action in and then we add in
some help some axioms right some
definition so the type right and then we
have this function that we can infer the
CSV type given some given the header
string just the header as a on parsed
ring and then we can actually create the
CSV type right so here I'm creating a
CSV type provider for some CSV data and
then we we have the the type provider
action like definition and so this is
see us i've called it CSV type I
probably should have named it something
else but the first argument is char
right so this is the delimiter the
second argument is the string and the
final part is an IO action we're inside
we're returning a provider of CSV type
and this is basically the the mechanics
of the provider part right all we're
doing here since a lot of you are
familiar with Haskell this should read
almost identically so we would read in
for the lines right from a file that is
given as the second argument and then we
do a pattern match on the line that are
returned and if the lines the lines from
the file are an empty list then we
report some kind of error and then if it
has at least one element we know it has
at least one element because it's not an
empty list then we can provide the
actual header right from the infer CSV
type okay so now we want to use this
thing so how do we go about that okay so
this is just boiler below this is just
the main stuff will import the module
that we just defined and this data named
vecht type which is not automatically
imported for us and we've created some
helper functions here get birthday and
get name this is the same data except on
CSV format of the JSON that we saw on a
previous on the f sharp slide so I'm
given a a row of type T which is the CSV
type that we infer then we produce a
string right which is the value at the
birthday column right given a row that's
this is all this is saying and the same
here with get name except we're changing
the name of the field okay so now this
is to use it we just say we want to use
the language extension type provider and
then this is really the magic this is
all there is to it almost right is that
we tell it okay we
want you well we want the type provider
using the CSV type function that we
defined in the module to read in that
file using this delimiter the second
argument the comma and we're going to
name that type T and so that T reference
is now available to us through the rest
of the file right and so this is what we
might do with that okay this is not very
interesting I admit all we're doing is
we're reading in that file and assuming
that we get some rows back we can just
map over all of the rows with get
birthday price birth year sorry and then
show all the birth years and do the same
for the name and get a show all of the
print line all of the the names okay not
very inspiring yet but as we can see we
can actually compute and calculate types
from some kind of external source right
so questions so far okay you still awake
I admit okay a couple so okay so there's
this other thing that I think is really
powerful in combination with using a
language like address and that is the
curry Howard correspondence so
informally we've got proposes
propositional logic right it it has a
number of concepts it has connectives
and it has quantifiers and some other
things that sound way too fancy for what
they are and they correspond to light a
programming language features and last
year at strange loop i believe philip
wad ler was presenting the keynote or at
least a talk on propositions as types
and if you haven't seen that you really
should and consequently the proofs in
some languages at least that have total
checking can are basically the proofs
are the definitions of those types of
the proofs okay so let's have a look at
a method anyone here afraid of maths
okay okay a couple ok this is this this
is only to show that
there is a mapping okay this is not some
horrible but it won't be too horrible i
think okay don't trust me at all but so
okay so a really simple proposition is
that for all n in the naturals right and
is either even or odd and the definition
we've got some definitions right so even
is defined as the sum p in the naturals
we've got n equals 2 to P and you know
for odd we've got the the you know to P
plus 1 right that's that's all this is
saying now the the second line here in
parentheses is a like a total math
encoding of this whole proposition right
so this is the very English version on
top right and this is just the mathy
version and that's kind of a little bit
programming language e maybe and so if
we look at how we could define this an
address right where we've basically got
this type so forum for all N and the
natural numbers right there exists a P
belonging to the natural numbers such
that it's either even n or odd n and
we're using types here too as basically
type constructors basically to the right
word to create a predicate right in this
case because we can't construct an even
value unless it really is even and i
think i have an example at the end so
this is proof by induction this is the
math induction I mean this is a math
proof right so we'll get to what the
idris definition looks like but first
let's just do a review right so we need
to encode we need to translate the
notion of truth to programming right and
in for example scholar we've got this
unit type and then in a dress
it's also called unit except it just
it's empty prams and this is very
similar to Haskell okay so falsity you
know is something that should never be
and so it needs to be uninhabitable and
that's just a fancy word for saying that
you should can never construct a value
of that right in your programming
language and this is sometimes called
the bottom type I just love saying the
bottom type and yeah so it in Scala is
called null this this type that's
available here to express this kind of
thing and in interest it's called void
and so if you ever needs to express in a
dress that something should never be
right then you can have it go to void a
TN done is basically you expressing that
this condition should never be met in my
program okay so so implication so when a
implies B we we can say given a value of
a we can return a value of B right
that's all that means and so this is
just going from A to B as a function and
defining that as a type and that's how
you would do it in skull on the top and
in the first two lines are what you
would do in a dress and then line four
five and six is the type signature and
definition for a really simple idea
right this is a proposition it not may
be very interesting yet but we've oh so
given a billion horrible value we can
return a gnat and in fact this is total
and I forgot to put total in there but
we can actually show that this is
consistent right in the logical
definition which just means that
everything checks out everything that
this function this type depends on is
just makes sense right there's no
comfort
and so given like there's only two
values ball so if it's false we return 0
in the naps and if it's true then we
return one that's all that is it's maybe
not the most interesting proposition but
you're starting to see that although
these things really are propositions but
we can make more interesting
propositions I'm sure of it so so
negation now there's a special type in a
dress for this and this is just not and
then in Scala we would just take an a if
something if if an a should never be if
an a should never exist we can just like
have it imply like this falsity thing
and that's all that means right so this
is logical not and we use this every day
and all of I if statements or whatever
right all Wiles or something like that
so this is not foreign to any of us I
think conjunction a really fancy word
for and we all use this right in on the
type level this can just be expressed as
a tuple right and in Scala that's how
it's written and then in interest that's
how it's written it's just a pair it's a
it takes to type arguments right and one
thing this can also you can also Express
this ending as a record type or product
so if you're familiar with that and I am
or so disjunction is a really fancy name
for exclusive or and in Scala I did say
it was kind of related to either the
standard library 10 almost right if
you're familiar with scholar said it's
more like disjunction the v1 and if
you're familiar with caps that's a lot
closer to the that's the sore and XOR
type and then in both Haskell and
adresses is either right and so okay so
consistency it's like in logic you just
want to make sure that all the
propositions when you combine them
together actually make sense right
everything
Sal and this would so when you say
consistency you want to make sure that
their total like all of the functions
that you care about well the types are
total and most languages don't actually
really give us this ability right not
not not quite to the extent that some of
these research languages have for a long
time and so we can express this an
address with total the keyword total and
we can even make it the default in our
file right and just say by default just
make everything total unless I want to
say it's partial in which case on line
13 you can see there we can say this
effect full name is is going to be
partial because you know we can't really
type check that if we say it's total and
it's really not okay so induction always
trying to say so induction is really
really important idea in mathematics and
logic you need to be able to prove
things a lot by this right and all we're
doing here is translating this to
recursion right and so a lot of
languages support this and this might be
like maybe the scariest slide so I
apologize so far but so given as her for
all n right in the naturals and for all
m and the naturals then and this is
actually a type this particular term
here and it's so the successor of n plus
M is the same as equivalent to n plus
the successor of em this is all this is
saying right I think this is pretty
common sense to most people we just take
this for granted but anyway so we can
actually prove this for oh sorry
apologies we can prove this with the
base case so Z is just a symbol for zero
and then M is just the second argument
here
and Idris can figure this out for us and
so we can just tell it raffle right and
then on line 6 we've got since this
isn't it isn't zero anymore because this
is just pattern matching right this is
just a new clause of the function and
this is a successor of case um k we
don't know what K is and then we take
the m and then we can do recursion right
here right oh sorry I'm I apologize i'm
i've renamed it to blah and I didn't
rename it in the definition so this
doesn't type check oh I cannot be
endorsed to type you know type-safe
presentations I guess I apologize so and
so qualifier is really really fancy word
for describe how many of something right
and so universal quantifier all that
means is for all X in something that's
all it means and it's not really that
interesting but this is an expression of
that in a dress right and so we can
label types in the type signature itself
and then use them later on and that's
what that means and then as the
existential quantifier is just saying
there exists something such that and so
you can read that here so for all em in
the naturals there exists a pea in the
naturals such that it's either even or
odd right so this is an approximation to
a proof of the very first like
proposition that we had right and this
is actually it's important now that we
see that all of the different things
that we just talked about the
translations from logic to programming
language features are you know might all
be there oops but it's really not that
hard to read this and of course I I
create I kept a tight hole because it
wasn't going to fit on the slide so I
apologize but in Idris you can have
these type holes and then fill things in
later when you
like it but this does in fact type check
the the original one I promise although
you don't trust me anymore because okay
so i know that was that was the most
mouth that you're probably going to get
today maybe hopefully i don't know but
so how would we encode more interesting
propositions about infrastructure well i
think i have a bug in the english so i
apologize so i'm going to read you the
type out loud in english so um we're
going to get an account and a region and
then an x and because we can because
we've got this we can define a type
provider right that extracts the number
of availability zones per region we can
get all this information then pump it
into this function right so this this
isn't this isn't a function that would
use the type provider or cool it or it
isn't the type provider action per se
but once we have that mechanism in place
and we've defined the provider and we're
in some kind of action that we can cool
the provider and get that extracted
information we can make more interesting
propositions about our infrastructure
and so X here will symbolize the number
of available sorry what was I thinking
here I need to write better names huh so
region net yeah so the number of
availability zones right which we
already know from when we build our type
provider and then we can say there
exists an N belonging to the national
numbers such that and here are some
definitions that are outside of the
scope of this particular slide but a
cluster of some multiple of x + m so x x
n and then for some service right so all
I'm saying here is that we're deploying
a cluster that is a multiple of the
number of available is and so we have
like an equal distribution of everything
and that that was what I intended to
write above and I didn't do so I
apologize for that and so we can
actually start expressing some of our
infrastructure requirements as types and
then using the address interactive type
checker to kind of give us hints on how
we could go about like proving that in
with our definitions and our axioms ok
so so what we've been able to do is
infer rules from evolvable metadata we
can proactively take advantage of new
account capabilities so we'll be reading
in you know the availability zones from
the AWS API at the time that we want to
create our deployment plan and we can
it's usable across accounts because we
just have to use different account
credentials right to be able to point at
the API and then we have this high-level
language with what I'm going to call
superior assurances so we could have
written a lot of this kind of
interactive stuff with Ruby but we don't
have a you know a number of things that
it resides in terms of the assurances we
can't do total checking you know we
can't check that a function is total we
can't check that you know that
everything is going to be appropriately
typed rice and things like that so idris
is something that can provide that for
us right so questions yes
fantastic question so there is I haven't
put any code you up yet because I didn't
want to put anything up but there's on
github are just created a repository
where I'm going to be putting up this
kind of thing and walking people through
not just this but also the you know how
we can encode propositions as types and
maybe creating various definitions that
would be useful for AWS kind of stuff so
so this will be there probably in the
next couple of days go ahead
oh okay in here
ok
oh ok great question that's a fantastic
question so I think on this slide I
didn't do a very good job of this but I
believe that so this is almost the same
thing just a slightly different such
that okay and so given an end so for all
an right there exists with P ball into
the nads such that is either even or odd
right and so here we show proof rights
we could have said rifle I think here
Idris would have been able to
oh sorry I understand the question so
this some this is a this this whole term
here is called a dependent pair in a
dress it is a special it has special
syntax you can represent it as a deep
air so the Deconstructor to look a
little bit Mozilla and so then the first
document would be the P like the labeled
P Coulomb net and then the second one
would be the the such that condition so
this is just special syntax and and so
the thing if you've got a something in
brackets and it's got a double asterisk
then what's beforehand is the there
exists such and then after that is the
such that condition yes yes yes thank
you for your question that was great go
ahead
what your name is
the for sure yes except that yes mmm it
is definitely similar to that I
definitely want to build out deployment
plans and also deployment execution
plans right so there's for example I
want to get to a point where i can
actually express in proposition or types
and then implement a something like i
want zero downtime of employments right
for this particular service and then it
would be able to either generate a
deployment plan that can do that or it
returns me something what an error right
yeah correct yes yeah go ahead
oh yes ah yes so here maybe this might
help a little bit so he this is a
realization of that type so this will
just boils down to it's right this is a
value of this type so this just becomes
a type and this is just special syntax
yes is the whole dependent pairs yes so
this last the result part is called a
deeper in a dress and is this particular
style is totally just in syntactic sugar
for for that deep air yeah and so this
is we're providing for the base case
here the evidence and is we're just
saying zero there exists a 0 such that
we can return left even 0 right we're
just providing that evidence for the
base case as a value of that time so go
ahead uh yes there is an error handling
portion in a dress work which allows you
to actually plug in like different error
messages depending on your domain
specific language I didn't I pulled that
out actually because I didn't have I
didn't think I had time that's a great
question so we would be able to say much
more concretely or more usable e to the
user you know hey we don't have the
requirement for you to deploy a
production cluster says that you need
three availability zones but you're this
region only has two available to you so
we can't do anything yeah any other
questions go ahead
sorry can you repeat that yes so
actually let me go back a little bit
nope so here okay so this is a regular
pair this is just a tuple but there's
also a deep air and it will take to it
will take one value of type something
like so it takes a it's to type
parameters writes a deep air right so
you've got the type of the the there
exists some value in that right and then
you've got the type which is
representing the predicate or the
particular proposition that you want to
hold so so in what might be confusing is
that an address predicates are basically
some value to type not some value to bul
bulls should probably never be in your
address programs so thank you for your
question I think one more oh no no more
sorry